so the Avengers disassembled event
brings us the conclusion of the entire
Avengers disassembled I guess storyline
then what we find here is that the
Avengers are now joined by Doctor
Strange now initially Doctor Strange
says he apologizes that he hadn't been
able to be here for the entire conflict
simply citing the fact that he had been
predisposed but what he tells the
Avengers is that someone somewhere is
molesting the MAGIX that someone is
using magic to do all of this now
initially the Avengers are trying to ask
who this person is they want to know who
it is that has done this and what Doctor
Strange
tells them is that he asked them is
there anyone they know who has such
power that they can manipulate reality
in this fashion that they can
effectively use magic for the purpose of
carrying out the things that have taken
place over the course of the day and so
what we do is we switch to Scarlet Witch
and Scarlet Witch is meeting with Agatha
Harkness and what's called at which asks
Agatha is why it is that people believe
that she has children and then she
immediately goes on a rampage and asks
Agatha Hartness what it is that has
happened to her children why it is that
they aren't there now we're not
immediately told what happens after this
in fact we don't really know all we know
is that somewhere along the line after
this meeting with Agatha Harkness The
Scarlet Witch began going on a rampage
against the Avengers which leads us to
believe that the scholar witch somewhere
along the line had connected two dots
that were previously unconnected and
that she had lost her children and the
Avengers had taken them so what happens
here as the Avengers begin to put
together what it is a Doctor Strange is
saying is that this cannot be the
Scarlet Witch that it's not possible
that the Scarlet Witch would go through
these steps and effectively try to kill
off all the Avengers and this is
believed by the Avengers for a couple
reasons the first is of course Scarlet
Witch is one of their own she has been
part of the Avengers for quite some time
but Nick Fury chimed in here and Nick
Fury says this is entirely possible to
the Scarlet Witch could do this and it's
entirely possible for a couple reasons
one because she was one of the first
members of the Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants under Magneto but more so than
that she had been left to the upper of
Magneto of a mutant terrorist who hated
humanity and who would go to
extraordinary steps in order to achieve
his goals and this really falls directly
in line with the kind of thing that that
that a magneto would do and so what
happens here is Doctor Strange begins
giving us an explanation
on the life of one a maximov he begins
telling us about how it is that her
powers exist in relation to her mindset
and this is extremely important the
reason why is because what Doctor
Strange is basically going to be telling
us here is that she has been
progressively becoming more and more
insane and he does this by telling us
now she was born into these powers she
was born into these abilities where
someone like dr. strange had learned
these abilities over the course of
tutelage with the ancient one she was
born into them but had no real
understanding of how they worked and so
the problem was that she would use
circumstances like conflict she would
use circumstances like the death of a
person to bring them back to life and to
subtly alter the world in a way that
would fit her image and show she has
been effectively warping reality over
time but the problem is that the longer
she does this the more she does this the
more insane she becomes the more she
begins to lose her grip on reality in
addition to this her entire past is
mired with loss and psychological
torment of course we had seen her lose
various individuals we had seen her and
the vision break apart we had seen them
of course split up we had seen her and
Wonder Man become a couple for a while
and then Wonder Man had left her and
then we saw of course the entire
upbringing she had where she was
manipulated psychologically by magneto
and so once she had learned that she had
had children and those children had
presumably been lost that was the final
straw
now when that one a maxima doesn't know
here is that her children were never
real that her children never existed as
she had basically conjured them into
existence and so once they had gone away
she was trying to figure out what it was
it had taken place that would led to
their existence and then led to them
disappearing and so what happens here is
the Avengers have a very hard time
picking up
on this they have a very hard time
believing that this would be the case
that one a Maximoff would effectively
wage war against the Avengers and so
Tony Stark says there's only one real
way to know this is sure there's only
one real way to know what it is it's
taking place with regards to one two
Maximoff and so what he does is have to
have a Doctor Strange transport them to
the home of one a Maximoff and so from
here we switch to the Scarlet Witch and
this is very important here and the
reason why is because what we see is
that the Scarlet Witch is having dinner
with Wonder Man with the vision with
Agatha Harkness and her sons but all of
this is an illusion
none of this is real this is all simply
just her warping reality and so what
happens as Captain America appears to
her and Captain America says he just
simply wants to help the Avengers want
to help her regain her sanity and to
bring this conflict to an end but
scholar which immediately lashes out and
what's really interesting here is that
her children effectively begin speaking
for her and it's basically with this
circumstance so she has two children
each one representing opposing parts the
the one child represents the aspect of
her that wants things to stay the same
that wants this perfect life that she
has envisioned for herself but the other
half is a logical side the side that
knows that she can't keep doing this but
ultimately one a maximov ends up
conjuring Red Skull along with a host of
Nazis that end up attacking Captain
America and so from here we see that she
begins to confront all the Avengers that
have gathered outside of her home and
she begins conjuring all different forms
of arch-nemesis of these various
Avengers taking it in turns for all the
Avengers to come into conflict as a
whole and so what we do is as conflict
continues as we see that Doctor Strange
eventually confronts when one two
Maximoff and when he does he tells her
this needs to end that this needs to
stop and what he does is he uses the eye
of agamotto to put her into a
psychological trance to effectively shut
her mind down and so when this time
comes
The Avengers band together and they try
to figure out what it does it needs to
be done here
but before they can take any further
steps magneto appears and magneto had
previously been informed by Charles
Xavier that everything that had taken
place on this day was due to the actions
one two maximov and so magneto realizing
that he had effectively failed her that
he had failed her as a father and had
instilled in her these psychological
torment takes her away to parts unknown
and that we'll find out in the House of
M storyline that he had actually taken
her due to Genosha alongside a
Quicksilver but what we do here is we
basically bring this story to a close we
bring this event to an end with the
Avengers try to figure out what is this
going on they try to figure out what's
taking place and of course they move on
with their normal lives albeit without
the financial support of Tony Stark with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates for Marvel explained and talk to
me directly